everybody's gonna have
they dry spots but i'll be feeling like
i'm more for the comeback story
i'm more for like damn how did you
bounce back off that [ __ ] come on man
they counted drake out
everybody was oh [ __ ] you had a son you
[ __ ] dead
it's because drake lost the battle i
didn't everybody
juice all over this is true and it
changed i remember seeing it with my own
eyes like and
everything changed i remember people
really trying to say like drake was done
i don't know about that no no no no no
no drake got fried up by
pushing me though i was like but it's
drake i was like i was living out here
none of drake's fans know who pushed the
tv
i was living out here they thought
aubry was done in the terms of that
battle he
was done they thought drake was
done they thought he was done for and
that was the only time he had any sort
of stench well not at the only time
shout out to uh quentin what's good yeah
that that quinton miller
that that was funny when he said uh
damn [ __ ] got points for saying i had a
son
listen man all i know you got points for
saying who my girl was
drake definitively and
you know what happened after that he
took the l and then god's plan came
of course that's not an l no no in that
specific battle now look i'm not cause i
don't want to [ __ ] on pusha t because
i'm i'm not
i'm i'm not i don't have anything to do
with that anymore no but push and push
and put put
through that out if i and drake never
even replied i could take if i could
take
that if i could take that one if that's
the last high point
that we have for pusha t oh come on
daytona came out after that
i said it's a classic album but you're
not talking to me about a classic album
right now you're talking to me about
a verse over a jay-z beat
which was a like little light something
and that was so light
and then i'm telling you and then god's
plan came out and then we forgot about
anything that had to do with pusha t now
i'm saying as far as drake go
because i can't do the first drink
because cause i gotta keep this a buck
right now i can't [ __ ] on pusha t like
pusha t
career don't take my career and like put
his foot on it
and like move it around a little bit
like that you know i'm saying i'm a
realist
but i'm also gonna be a realist and tell
you
after that high point for pusha t
i don't remember look and somebody might
be like mills i don't remember a high
point from you ever shut up
tony technically came out just haven't
we just having regular
just regular conversation yeah listen
push your teeth for a long time
but look but look look cause i love
drake man i love drake
anything with young money involved i'm
taking the young money side i don't give
a [ __ ]
but he lost drake did he lost ordered a
microphone
with pusha t's uh autograph on it
back in the days yeah cause i remember
when i seen that and i was like you
might you might
that was like a bad one but then you
know but then that turns out
that turns into like the super seniors
still bothering the freshman it's like
bro go to college
that pushes that guy bro now push it
look listen
it's probably not impossible for drake
to like lose in the grand scheme of
things because he's the biggest
ever you look people you can we're
[ __ ] this no you can't lose
you can lose because people you you have
people that will say
nah drake lost that battle then you have
people out to say you won the battle
you got people who's saying he won the
battle you will literally have people
that
they're like 12 year old white kids who
don't know what what what
you know what you're saying right now
you move in the goal post the goal post
is who cares how old they are there are
people that will say ether was
whack because they are jay z stands
first of all i'm a naz stan i'm a
nonstand too and you're not
my favorite mca tell me the beat was
whack but also tell me you know what
ether was before that
yeah okay so listen
in retrospect in retrospect
say it take over was it safe no no but
takeover wasn't
a spec it was there was a noz line in
there
right if we're talking about which song
is
better sonically to listen to
i can why does he move the goalpost no
no no no cause
ether is a better diss record but this
but which song is better to listen to i
didn't ask you which song was better i
said who lost
jay-z and i said there are people like
you who still say but the beast
electronically
it's almost like when you watched belly
as a kid and you were like yo this [ __ ]
is fire but then you watch it as a
grown-ass man
and you like the last 20 minutes i mean
you're like watching but it's really a
good movie if you've been hustling and
you went out of town and you got money
yeah but it's and you had to drive
around and intrepid and a [ __ ] snitched
on you and then you was getting money
and then you had to leave
you did that before belly's a great
movie it's
i don't know if you did that before i
don't know you keep saying
there's people that say drake drake won
the battle oh y'all
y'all are real y'all really like pusha t
in there i like pushing t2 i
love the album like what are you talking
about
you said oh okay so who won who won the
battle
the overall battle no he won the battle
or the 444
freestyle and the other [ __ ] like the
other [ __ ] both of them i like so
hopefully
freestyle because it had i didn't we
didn't know he had a son
you think drake should have shoulda
replied
i think that would have been good for
rap i think that would have been good
for rap if you'd applied
i think it was a bad look that he didn't
reply and it was a bad look that
that wasn't that similar did meek reply
well no meek didn't need to reply
because jesus christ
his reply to [ __ ] back to back was
atrocious it was right
he ruined the undertaker's theme song it
was really bad
it was over it was like okay dude drake
just hit you with two of them bro
and then you coming back with this
[ __ ] but but see on top of that
and listen but i and and and i'm not the
biggest drake fan in the world but he
undoubtedly beat the [ __ ] out of meek
mill and that it was
it wasn't even a [ __ ] question it was
really sad i remember we were in tampa
and i was just sitting there like man it
might really be over for me man
because he this was when he was on
twitter tweeting up a storm
because that's when you know he was like
what he had the trump twitter fingers
and you know what it'd be sometimes too
you know it'd be sometimes too
sometimes you can dig a hole with
uh the fans i know this from battling
like
right you can talk so much [ __ ] that
they want to see you lose like
i think that's what happened with meek
like drake not to say like back to back
but listen meek jumped out though
yeah he was talking crazy you you you
made it with drake looked like he was
countering
so you made people be like you made
people pick sides you made them be like
now we like him more than you even if
you're right
yeah but you know what i'm saying even
if you're giving us you know to go back
to
the kanye jay-z [ __ ] even if you're
giving us evidence and you're right
we don't care um that's what i
seen at that time and i think oh yeah no
one cared they were like what's
going on who cares we don't give a [ __ ]
we still like him more than you
and that's i think that's when it was
just like hold up
he don't write he didn't write that [ __ ]
though so we don't care
i need one dance and we're going to sing
those songs too hey back-to-back was
crazy
the fact that you had to go to a
nightclub for x amount of years and hear
the dis song
in every club for two years straight
that [ __ ] was
i'm a fan i'm a fan of all of the diss
record [ __ ] that's why i like this type
of conversation whether it's pushers
drake
no nods won the whole drake or knives or
whole nope
whoever you i don't care if you want to
talk about kim in 50s closest beef ever
though
being seagull and jada yo how did you
take that
look at here why this [ __ ] took it here
i earned my spot
ain't nobody putting me here closest
cause that was you hear the beanie [ __ ]
and the jada [ __ ] you're like oh
that matters so now this conversation is
going somewhere else
that was a time of like
that was like a real time of like [ __ ]
studying like them diss raps
when i'm talking about the crews i was
talking about
d block and dip set g unit state
property
i remember that beef that beef went for
a long time that beef went from dj clue
mixtapes to
state property would drive from philly
to new york and go up the funk master
flex and rap for an hour [ __ ] spj hood
die too looking out for nazia [ __ ] when
i find you i'm like whoa
like they're from philly they're at the
radio station on hudson street right now
this is live this isn't like a
pre-recorded thing and then like two
days later
kissing them would come up there or
styles will come out with some [ __ ] [ __ ]
beanie seagull you could suck my dick
with the [ __ ] up on it whoa whoa
what did he just say they got to see
each other at some point
you know what i'm saying so that's why
when i think about like the new beefs
and it's like
somebody might put out a freestyle and
then this one put out like
nah this [ __ ] went from powerhouse to
live performances and [ __ ] throwing
french fries at [ __ ] on that stage
kiss came out on stage in philly that's
that's right see that's different than
you freestyle over somebody beat and you
put it out and i hear what you're saying
with that being said
that was great replied
i waved the white flag and said [ __ ] got
too real guys i got it